hello UK welcome to my British
Countryside Family Vacation
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to my channel for
the next 16 days I'm gonna be here in
the beautiful British Countryside of the
Cotswolds uh most people know the
Cotswolds as the place where you may run
into a certain Jude Law and like a cozy
little Pub midwinter Ella the holiday uh
and while I'm not gonna not keep my eyes
open for Mr law outside cozy Pub I'm
technically here with my kids and my
husband which maybe is like a little
less romantic but it's what I got and
I'm actually really really excited about
it so come with me a little British
Adventure as I share everything I eat
everything I do and everywhere I go on
holiday it might not be Beach weather
but it is damn beautiful here so first I
want to hop in here quick to tell you
about my sponsor Miro so I am a planner
always have been always will be hashtag
Taipei and I take great pleasure in
planning out our family trips while
still trying to leave some room for
flexibility spontaneity and fun but I
recently discovered Miro for work and it
turned out to be a huge asset for help
me to conceptualize our UK trip so for
my trip I use the Mind map template
which basically just helped me keep
track of all the little things that I
read about the Cotswolds online so when
it came time to do like a day trip I
would know what we wanted to check out
you can also easily share the map with
family so my husband and I could both
have a reference for what we want to do
on each day I also used it as like a
packing and to-do list for my husband
and I because I needed to remind him
weeks in advance to like get his
passport renewed and ensure that we had
a rental car lined up those are like
basically some of the only jobs that I
gave him but at least with the reminders
I was sure he was gonna get to them so
Miro has not only been super useful in
my business but also for all of these
little personal events as well but if
you want to try out mirror yourself you
can check out my link in the description
to sign up for free before we get into
it I quickly want to share a disclaimer
that I will be talking about my body and
weight loss and I also ask that you
refrain for making any comments about my
body in the comments okay folks let's
get to the Vlog okay folks let's talk
vacation eating so as you guys know I'm
an intuitive eater so I don't have
strict rules that I follow when it comes
to what I eat or when I eat it or how
much I eat Etc but when I'm at home I'm
working I've got my kids in school and
we've got a hard schedule around here we
basically work hard during the week and
play hard on the weekends because that's
basically all we have the energy to do
so as a result you know my whole family
has a pretty regimented eating and meal
schedule so you know I eat my breakfast
around nine I have my lunch around one
I've got my dinner around six and I have
a bedtime snack and I allow myself
treats throughout the week but I would
say that most of my indulgent meals
happen on the weekend when I actually
have time to go out with my husband and
our friends and it's usually kind of all
happening at once so like I'm having the
wine I'm having the big dinner and I'm
having dessert because I'm going out but
when I'm on vacation it's like there is
no schedule there is no routine so we're
going out for lunch one day maybe we're
staying in and making something kind of
a little bit more nourishing with more
vegetables at night the next day we
might go for brunch and maybe have a
little sip of wine midday so I just find
that these opportunities to like get out
of your routine are really good for
getting back in tune with your hunger
and your fullness cues and also those
satisfaction signals um because you know
it's a good reminder that tomorrow is
going to be another delicious day right
like you don't have to finish the bottle
of wine tonight you can have a little
bit today have a little tomorrow you
don't have to have dessert when you go
out for dinner if you don't want to
because you're probably going to go out
for another meal at some point on your
trip obviously acknowledge that this is
a privilege
um so I'm not suggesting that everyone
should just go on holiday or go on
vacation in order to get back in tune
with their hunger and fullness cues but
whatever you can do to kind of strip
away those routines at least
periodically I find to be a really good
kind of mental reset and speaking of
mental reset
wowie wow wow wow honestly like this
place is pure magic I might never ever
leave like it feels like I'm in Snow
White surrounded by all these
breathtaking fairy forests and
wildflowers and Woodland creatures like
we literally have deer and bunnies in
our yard every morning and we've got
cows and sheep on our property that we
pass by every day it is heaven on Earth
here for my boys which obviously means
it is Heaven for me and speaking of mom
life let's get back to my full-time job
of buying and prepping and pecking
delicious snacks take a look another day
another shopping trip because when
you've got a family with three boys in
it you go through a lot of food
especially produce and I've got two
interesting observations here when it
comes to British food at the grocery
store one
is with all the plastic
literally everything you buy fruits and
vegetables
come in plastic like this and the worst
Beware of the plastic outside of bananas
and a whole pineapple I bought
everything comes in plastic I don't
understand that when they won't even
give you a plastic bag for your grocery
shopping which they shouldn't but then
they do this I don't get that
but second observation which I actually
like is that they I don't know if this
is a law or if this is just what they
voluntarily do but on their ingredient
list they actually list out the
percentage of what each ingredient makes
up
um and this is really great especially
for parents because a lot of times
marketer will make it seem like there's
you know tons of fruits and vegetables
or real fruit or you know made with real
fruit or real real vegetables in a
particular product especially when it's
marketed towards children but this will
tell you exactly what is in that food so
if you just like had a smidgen like a
milligram worth of broccoli in something
you would know that because it would say
it's only like 0.5 percent broccoli so
in this case I bought these like
smoothies when I ordered online thinking
it was it would be more like an actual
thick smoothie but actually it's 47
apple juice so whatever the kids are
enjoying these and they're great because
I use them as a basis for smoothies
which I add like yogurt to but they're
not exactly the same as like making a
smoothie at home because half of it is
basically just juice anyways America
Canada please catch up because I am all
about transparency and I love this level
of transparency and this seems like a
good time to talk about exercise on
vacation so
you know I do little workouts on the
floor I have some equipment in my home
um I play tennis regularly but here
really all I have are a couple ankle
weights an exercise band and some five
pound dumbbells and the kids are also
basically on top of me anytime I try to
use them because this is not a very
large rental house so I'd really only
ever get like 15 minute bursts of super
low impact exercise time which really
just ended up being kind of like quiet
time for me and then the rest of the two
weeks I was just walking I did play
tennis once and I also went horseback
riding though I was obviously just
sitting on my ass for that but otherwise
I was just kind of moving and exploring
and that's okay like that's what
holidays are all about gentle joyful
movement a few weeks out of the gym is
not going to make or break anything if
anything it's nice to give my body a
break and Hiking through the beautiful
Cotswold Countryside or even better
doing a little shopping in London is a
way more fun to get in my daily movement
okay folks let's talk about building
balanced meals while traveling and yes
I'm still wearing this same sweater
because I packed really poorly and this
is the only sweater I brought
so I'm wearing it even though it's dirty
um but anyways what is my game plan here
so number one I'm always thinking about
enjoyment and experience this is really
no different than when I'm at home but
it's particularly important I think when
you know you're on some kind of like
novel vacation or holiday because you're
never going to look back in 20 years oh
spiderweb you're never gonna look back
in 20 years and think oh I'm so glad I
just ate salad on that trip but you will
look back and think I really wish that I
tried that you know local specialty
Cuisine I'm so glad I had the fish and
chips or I'm so glad I had that unique
uh special dessert I'm so glad that I
tried that that wine I know that
enjoyment and experience is really
really important because otherwise if
you just live in a state of denial
you're gonna probably binge and number
two I think about my Hunger crushing
combo fiber protein and healthy fats so
as you guys know it is a framework it's
not a rule but generally speaking you
know we want to try to get in fiber
Protein healthy fats at most meals and
snack on the day-to-day in order to feel
our best and everyone's priorities of
the hierarchy for fiber Protein healthy
fats is going to be unique and that
might be unique for specific scenarios
for specific goals just what feels best
to you or what your preferences are for
me my hierarchy at home normally is
usually protein fiber and then fat but
when I'm here my priority is actually
fiber protein and then fat see the
distinction and there's a really good
reason for this because as I mentioned I
have ibsc and it's pretty well managed
at home on the regular when I'm in my
usual routine but it can get thrown off
anytime I'm traveling or in times of
stress or any kind of Novel food
experiences so that means when I'm
building a meal or out for dinner or out
for lunch and I'm choosing what I'm
going to order I'm not thinking about
the calories at all I'm thinking about
can I get in a source of fiber because
it's actually always the hardest thing
to do when you eat in restaurants is to
find those vegetables right protein and
a restaurant meal pretty easy to find
fat very easy to find Fiber though in
any kind of meaningful quantities can be
a bit more of a challenge so for me that
means I'm just trying to look for fruits
vegetables whole grains and if I really
haven't gotten much in the day I'll
always have a really high fiber snack
before bed so like pears raspberries my
kiwis which you know are really great
for for ibsc as well yeah I just know
for me that without getting that fiber
in I'm gonna get an IBS flare and it's
not going to be a good trip but I'm
really curious to know what hunger crush
and combo hierarchy works best for you
in your life okay so obviously eating
for IBS is a priority for me but I will
never let that get in the way of my fun
so let me quickly show you some of the
delicious things that I ate so as you've
always
to the house because I've got kids which
meant that we had a nice balance of
eating out and some casual cooking at
home usually we would have breakfast at
home so basic stuff oatmeal toast eggs
whatever was easy and also by the way
the eggs here are out of control
gorgeous like they don't even look real
but anyways then we would often eat
lunch on the go while exploring little
towns or Villages I basically just try
to enjoy a balance of different fresh
salads and fish and chips and pizza high
tea sandwiches Sunday roasts like like
whatever was on the menu that sounded or
felt appealing to me in that moment I
really never deny myself any food
experiences especially when traveling
but as I discussed I do keep my Hunger
crushing combo in the back of my mind
just to make sure that I know that I can
feel my best on the trip dinners I would
say we did a lot of like simple family
meals just stuff that I knew that the
kids would like including baking some
cookies with the kids one day and on a
few occasions my hubby and I escaped and
splurged on some unique date nights
pretty kids my husband and I solely
traveled for food so it's really nice to
do a few child-free leisurely fancy
meals whenever we're traveling we ended
up going to London on two different
occasions uh the first night we ate at
dinner by Heston blumen fall which is a
two Michelin star and the second time we
went to Evelyn's table which is a one
Michelin star both were really really
really good well this is gorgeous isn't
it
God I need my sunglasses it is hot wow
what a blessing okay so check it in with
a little Vlog here just want to tell you
what's on my mind today
um but I did want to issue a trigger
warning about what I'm gonna say I'm
going to be talking about body weight
I'm sort of eating Etc I have a tendency
to lose a little bit of weight whenever
I go on vacation
um and I acknowledge that that's not an
experience that maybe a lot of you can
relate to
um but for me it's pretty common because
I am an intuitive eater and so when I'm
out and about on holiday I'm just busier
right like I am out walking so much more
I'm sitting down and eating basically
just at meal time so a lot less snacking
I'm not sitting at my desk kind of like
bored eating
um and so as a result what I'm noticing
is that because we're just so busy in
the day I'm eating as much as I possibly
can at my meals and then I go to bed and
I'll wake up at four in the morning and
be like Oh I'm hungry and as a result I
think I'm losing a little bit weight and
I don't like that I looked at myself in
the mirror today and I thought oh gosh
I'm looking way skinnier than I'm
comfortable looking and then I also just
thought back to being in London a few
days ago where I was trying on jeans and
doing it really really quickly before my
I needed to go get my kids but I was a
little distressed because the size of
jeans that I was putting on is certainly
not my normal size jeans and I looked at
the size and I thought I can't buy these
because it was super triggering for me
it just kind of reminded me of some of
the worst years of my life and so this
is all a really good reminder to me that
I need to slow down even when I'm out
and about traveling with my kids and
things are chaotic and I'm not sitting
down properly to eat I mean I'm rushing
through meals with my kids because they
are like tears in the restaurant they're
still these are covered kids so we
haven't had a whole lot of experience in
restaurants yet so it's stressful to eat
with my children
to say the least
and um I am finding that perhaps I'm not
able to listen to my Hunger cues as well
when I'm feeling rushed and on the go
and constantly seeing things and over
stimulated with just all the action so
this is a good reminder to myself that I
might need to just eat a little bit more
than I think I need or what I feel like
I'm hungry for and I'm gonna have to
take more mindful breaks throughout the
day to refuel have more snacks and just
maybe choose even more higher calorie
things which again I know a lot of you
guys are thinking oh
you're so lucky and in a lot of cases
absolutely yes but the fact that I'm an
intuitive eater I don't get to these
holidays and feel like I need to over
indulge and binge I can still just
listen to my body
um and those hunger cues and what I know
feels good to my body in terms of
balanced meals but in this case
specifically I feel like
um I need to make an effort to eat even
more so yeah let me be the content
creator the one person on these apps who
is suggesting that maybe sometimes less
isn't more and on that note I'm actually
hungry because we are home today and I'm
able to really acknowledge those hunger
cues we're not out and about we're doing
our thing I think it's time for lunch
okay so I'm just starting to get myself
organized and rearrange and pack things
which means we're nearing the end of our
trip and I'm embarrassed to say that it
just dawned on me like today that the
reason perhaps why I haven't been able
to kind of like eat intuitively with my
actual caloric needs which are likely
quite enhanced on this trip due to all
the activity and like slipping and lack
of desk work I guess you could say
um is because my circadian rhythm is all
up like I've gone these two weeks
feeling pretty nauseous every morning I
was thinking like maybe it says Coffee
that I not is not settling well with me
I was like I feel nauseous every morning
and that is interfering with my ability
to eat my generally typical sized
breakfast or even have an appetite for
breakfast at all and that's also why I'm
getting up in the middle of the night to
have like a big snack it's because my
body and brain still thinks that it's
dinner time when it's midnight and that
when it's breakfast time here it's like
the middle of the night so of course I'm
not gonna have an appetite and feel kind
of sick when I'm forcing myself to eat
it's all making sense we're at the end
of the trip here so I'm really not sure
how many improvements we're going to be
able to make in a few days before I give
my whole body another slap in the face
with a circadian rhythm destruction but
at least I will know for next time not
to like force my body into having
breakfast at a certain time if it
doesn't feel like it and instead work
with my body and focus on having like a
really big hearty bedtime snack AKA like
a whole other meal in order to meet my
typical caloric needs making that a
priority is an act of self-care because
I know that's what my body actually
needs as I always say guys intuitive
eating is a journey it's all about
learning your body's cues collecting
data and those data cues what I think I
know about my body is going to change
when everything gets turned on its head
as clearly it has obviously if I were to
see here in the UK for like several more
weeks or months I would be able to flip
the switch figure it out and easily get
back on track with meeting my
nutritional needs intuitively but
because things are not feeling normal to
me it means that I may have to kind of
juggle things around and make a point to
eat a larger meal in that evening time
frame just simply as an act of self-care
so yeah you live and you learn and I'm
gonna go home in a couple days and my
body and my Hunger cues and my intuition
as I know it is all gonna get back on
track and on that note let's get a snack
so we just got back from our second trip
to London which was so nice little child
free Escape there and the good news is
that I guess I had a little bit of a
false panic attack about the weight loss
at my last London trip whatever pair of
pants I tried on the sizing was totally
off because basically everything I tried
on on this trip fit pretty true to my
normal size but I think this speaks to a
really relatable experience that seeing
any kind of external number or size or
weight can really trigger us like it can
really throw off our mood for the entire
day in my case seeing a smaller pant
size than I'm used to seeing in my kind
of normal healthy state was really
triggering for me like it brought me
back to really problematic days but for
most people including myself sometimes
seeing a size of pants that is larger
than what we're used to seeing can feel
really really anxiety provoking right
you immediately think oh I can't buy
that you know like your turn off the
pants even if they look really really
great on you and it puts you in a really
Sourpuss mood so this is a gentle
reminder not to let the size of your
pants or the number on your scale or any
kind of like blips you see like that
ruin your day and speaking of a really
good mommy here I admittedly went a bit
crazy in London I don't know I had my
head this is like definitely an ADHD
thing that yeah if I'm gonna shop this
is the place to do it and I always have
buyer's remorse and I have it right now
and I'm feeling a little guilty I'm not
gonna lie but you might as well enjoy a
little fashion show so let's do it
everyone loves a fashion show
[Music]
thank you
okay guys I'm gonna interrupt the
beautiful idyllic aesthetic that is the
Cotswolds to talk to you about ghosts
this feels like a little bit of a
Beetlejuice moment especially because
I'm standing in front of Amir
um and I probably shouldn't
be but this is the area that um I've
been staying in it's kind of like a
really old original Barn I'm sleeping up
there and I think it's from like the
1600s and I am 100
that it is
definitely
I don't want to say it out loud because
I don't want to like
stir up any activity we'll just say but
I was sleeping the other night and I was
awoken at 4am not by my children which
is typical but because I felt and saw a
child shake me awake I don't know how to
explain this could have been a dream
could be the fact that I take a lot of
drugs but I've never had anything like
that happen to me before exactly where I
wake up and I feel kind of in a dream
state kind of not in a dream state but
pretty sure there was a child shaking me
awake but yeah now that I've kind of put
that out into the world I'm just hoping
that there's not more Mischief no more
wake-ups my kids can wake me up but not
another random kid please
well guys I am happy to report no more
official activity but I'm sad to report
that means it's time to go home
always so depressing when these things
come to an end but I gotta say that I
feel like the British Countryside
Toronto where I live at home and you
know my husband and I are just
constantly toying with the idea of
getting out of the city you know yes it
was fun when we were young and single
and we didn't have kids but now that we
do have kids it just doesn't feel like
the right environment and atmosphere to
raise the kinds of human beings that we
want in this world you know like we just
feel like we can't give our kids the
opportunity to be at one with nature and
get curious when they're confined to
this tiny box and anything outside of
that is super dangerous or like a safety
concern like they're just way too many
no's or don't do that or don't go there
be careful like way too many don'ts when
we want to Foster independent humans to
be able to explore and make decisions
and mistakes for themselves and you just
can't do that in the city because we're
like afraid of I don't know getting
kidnapped or traffickers or like a car
hitting you so yeah I don't know how
easy it is to get a British passport if
anyone's going through that please let
me know I I definitely have British
ancestry but my grandfather was just
barely born in Canada his parents were
pregnant with him and his siblings were
all born here in the UK but he was not
so I feel like it's going to be a bit of
a tricky go but I may or may not be
Googling this all the way home
but I hope you guys enjoyed my little
holiday Vlog if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you guys have any
questions or if you have any
recommendations for like getting a Visa
or something just saying and thanks
again to Mira for helping me plan this
trip and helping my business run
smoothly back at home for this Taipei
YouTuber and I'll see you next time back
in the kitchen at Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]